- Are we finishing all of them?
- Chug, chug, chug, chug, go!
(techno music)
- I would say I drink coffee
maybe a few times a week tops,
I definitely don't drink it daily.
- I kinda lean towards the sweet side,
and get like four to six packs
of sugar, don't judge me.
- I would rather not have coffee at all,
than to have it with milk, or black,
it needs to be with cream.
- I wish I could be one
of those cool people
who only drinks black coffee.
- I really don't drink coffee that often,
but I'm easing into it like a badass
and I only drink it black.
- If I'm just like, in a
bad mood I'll just drink
it black and make myself more miserable.
- I mean, that's the
best thing about coffee,
you can cater it to your taste.
(techno music)
- I can be with iced coffee.
- Mmmm, thank you.
- Yeah, it looks pretty normal.
- Innocent enough.
- It smells really good.
- Yeah.
- Sort of like a sweet coffee.
- Let's give it a whirl.
- Do we go for it?
- Ooh, mama.
- It's really sweet.
- I like that.
- It's good though.
- It is like a little bit thick.
- Ooh, thicc, with a 'c'.
- That is probably the proper thick.
- I would hydrate with this.
- Really?
- I could like, come into
the office and grab one
of these bad boys every
morning, done and done.
- It's like a wawa ice coffee.
- Anything with condensed milk is amazing.
- I'm with it.
- A plus.
- Kudos to the Vietnamese.
(chill music)
- Interesting color going on here.
- This looks like iced tea.
- Watch it be iced tea,
it's gonna be iced tea.
- No, it's gonna be coffee.
- Wow, that has like, some
sour undertones going on.
- It tastes like iced tea.
- It does taste like iced tea.
- Ah, see?
- Is there coffee in this?
- I don't hate it, I would
drink this at brunch.
- Yeah, same.
(Greek Music)
- Artisanal.
- This is Greek coffee?
- I feel like it's gonna be desserty.
- Do I need to stir it?
- I think you should.
- Oh, it smells strong.
- I think there's a lot
of caffeine in this.
- See what this tastes like.
- Oh.
- I feel like I'm gonna grow
a mustache drinking this,
this is so f(bleep)ing heavy.
- Tastes like a firework.
- Tastes like smoked coffee.
- When you let off a firework
and like the smoke and all
that gets in your face.
- I get what he's saying.
- It's gorgeous in presentation.
At first glance I'd be like, oh,
this is probably gonna
taste good, but nope.
- I'm gonna pass on this one.
- Me too.
- I'm not gonna lie, it kinda
has grown on me a little bit.
(upbeat music)
- I like the display of it.
- Not a super strong smell.
- I like this glass.
- It's like the normal
color of my coffee I would say.
- Smells like it's gonna be really good.
- Alright, let's see then.
- Oh my god, this tastes amazing.
- It has an aftertaste of green tea.
- It's a little more watered down
then I thought it would be,
not a super strong flavor
but it tastes pretty good.
- I think I would rather
just drink tea or coffee,
I don't really need them together.
- It tastes like green tea
so, misleading, I pass.
(techno music)
- Austrians, what are you
doing that you're putting
raw egg in your coffee?
- Mmmm.
- That smells very strongly like eggs.
- Is it 'cause we know
they're eggs in there?
- That's what I was gonna say.
- I mean, the color
looks nice, it looks like
any other normal coffee.
- I don't trust it.
- I'm so nervous 'cause I
already know what's in it
and I don't want...
You go first.
- To raw eggs.
- I'm gonna go for it.
- You just took a, he
just took a big ass sip.
- That's good.
- Oh my god, that's really good.
What?
- If you don't look too
close at the chunks of egg
it tastes pretty damn good.
- Why did you just draw my attention to
the chunks of eggs.
- Oh my god!
- You can keep talking,
I will keep drinking,
'cause this is amazing.
- It's definitely a morning coffee.
And you get a little breakfast in it too.
- I think the egg thing
does kinda go to your head
a little bit but I don't think
I have a big problem with it.
Instead of cooking it just
throw it in your coffee.
- [Man Offscreen] This one
is, sweetened condensed milk,
coffee, black tea, and ice.
- There's tea in it, that's, ah!
The tea, that's the note I, oh my god,
this is combining coffee and tea?
Those are okay.
- Hong Kong peeps.
(electronic music)